[Musique]
dominique boucheron bonjour vous où
brice marronniers bonjour jours merci à
tous les deux d'être revenu sur un
plateau tv soixante dix huit pour celui
que l'on va vous consacrez jutra fiers
de vous recevoir tous les deux deux
champions et voilà si c'est rare vous
êtes ici parce que vous avez vous allez
participer à un événement qui est donc
le triathlon de la pièce d'eau des
suisses qui a lieu pièce d'eau des
suisses
c'est le 6e triathlon nationale en duo
parce que vous dominique vous êtes
aveugle et vous brice ma moynier vous
est amputé d'une jambe et vous êtes
surtout le parrain de cet événement tout
en fait voilà donc dominique vous allez
participer à ce triathlon
quels sont les 3
les trois supports les trois commandés
trois épreuves des trois épreuves
étaient alors il ya trois épreuves donc
un triathlon normal c'est de la course à
pied de la natation et du vélo oui chez
nous ça sera de la course à pied canoë
kayak et du temps des nains d'accord
donc ça lieu le samedi 15 juin ça c'est
dit voilà évidemment vous êtes en duo
avec eux vous êtes avec françois par
exemple oui vous avez votre duo habituel
mon binôme voilà vino mon guide
voilà très bien et vous appartenez à la
fondation valente a eu enfin vous êtes
bénévole si j'assume voilà association
sensation ta vie où je suis bénévole
depuis une quinzaine d'années maintenant
les relations valentin avis étant
l'association qui oeuvre pour
l'autonomie des personnes déficientes
visuelles aveugles et malvoyantes
d'accord et vous alors brice marmonnier
vous êtes depuis vous êtes un rugbyman à
la base
bon moi j'ai grandi par mail - ferrand
et d une carrière de sportif j'ai fait
mes études dans le sport jusqu'à la
taille
aujourd'hui je suis comme ça y est
exactement sur les deux d'ailleurs ici
ville de versailles aussi je les
remercie ouais voilà j'ai fait ma
carrière dans le sport grave accident de
la route il ya un match à gagner en 2004
j'ai fait le choix d'être amputé en 2015
c'est-à-dire que vous avez subi de
nombreuses opérations j'ai subi 28 des
opérations c'était un défi je me suis
toujours battue et puis je me suis battu
jusqu'à choisir de me faire amputer
c'est un choix qu'on fait parce que ben
voilà les douleurs sont là et que à un
moment il faut passer à autre chose
c'est de toute façon excusez moi je vous
écoute mais parce que votre gendre ne
pouvait vraiment à la veille journée en
enfer tout mon but était de repartir
dans le sport
dans le sport et de rotalier haut niveau
et dans la vie et le fait de le faire ça
bien réussi j'ai basculé d'abord en
aviron sur lequel j'ai pris un titre de
champion de france au bout d'un an j'ai
continué puis après j'ai basculé sur le
triathlon j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer la délégation française est
de courir aujourd'hui sur
l'international dans différentes manches
de coupe du monde et n'a par exemple si
on m'invite à new york dans mi juillet
pour aller courir aussi sur une autre
distance
bon bah c'est plutôt une belle aventure
et abat entre entre triathlète athlètes
on se retrouve tous et voilà le
triathlon magique rôle triathlon de
versailles il ya une quinzaine de jours
oui à celui des valides entre guillemets
vraiment de versailles qui est organisée
de manière avec c'était très attendu roi
ses 550 athlètes valides
donc exit ouais je suis le seul
handisport à venir le courir bon c'est
celui de mon club donc c'est normal que
je ne veux courir
et puis a toujours ce petit cette petite
effervescence d'avoir d'avoir l'athlète
handisport de la ville qui est là donc
c'est toujours sympathique et il ya
toujours une bonne ambiance dans la
ballade ans le 15 juin il ya le
triathlon duo que vous avez donc accepté
de parrainer exactement malheureusement
je serai pas là parce qu'il ya une
manche de coupe du monde de triathlon
qui a lieu hors dernière des lettres de
haut niveau au bij fois après dépend de
la chance d'avoir des dossards vous pas
aussi puisque c'est une année de
présélection jeux olympiques donc les
défunts oui il ya la peau de dossards
cette année puisque justement il ya
beaucoup d'athlètes qui essaye de
récupérer des points parle aux jeux
olympiques donc quand on en a il faut
faut y aller c'est un peu votre
mentalité j'ai l'impression de 16 ans et
dominique c'est pareil dominique vous
êtes kinésithérapeute
vous êtes en
édité depuis quelques années ses
services depuis qu'un mode mi6 negra
vous sert donc maintenant vous évoluez
beaucoup dans le monde du sport pratiqué
quoi comme sport alors je pratique
essentiellement du tandem wyss et voilà
c'est mon sport de base on va dire à gré
préférées mais avant d'avoir d'être
totalement aveugle j'ai fait beaucoup
d'autres sports j'ai fait de la
gymnastique les voiles et is no longer
du handball voilà j'ai toujours été
depuis tout toujours sportives
j'ai une longue interruption parce que
quand on commence à perdre la vue on se
dit que c'est plus possible
et puis en plus j'étais maman j'avais
trois enfants mais c'est toujours top
mais ils sont grands ils s'arrêtent au
dos maintenant
et voilà je me suis pas donné
l'opportunité de faire du sport et je me
suis remise au sport en 2008 2009
environ en faisant du tandem
et puis là je me suis dit que tout était
possible pour nous donc dans ce ce
triathlon vous avez là qu'en fait ce qui
est bien si j'ai bien compris c'est
qu'on peut avoir n'importe quel niveau a
bien totalement voilà le triathlon
battue mais je veux dire de la bh oui de
l'association valentin lui où il produit
du kent voilà le premier but le premier
objectif c'est de
rassembler un maximum de déficients
visuels de toute la france oui c'est
pour la pour
un premier premier but prendre le
plaisir de passer une très bonne journée
tous ans déjà voilà faire du sport
ensemble prouver qu' on peut être
aveugle et on peut faire du sport et
c'est possible c'est possible oui la
compétition bien sûr mais on n'est pas à
un niveau national ou international
comme peut l'être comme d'autres voient
la mémé
à tout niveau on peut faire du sport et
prendre du plaisir moi le premier
triathlon que j'ai fait je ne courrai
pas du tout
oui on que l'épreuve course à pied levé
de faire marcher et je vais pas gagner
et peu importe
et bien voilà rester parce qu'il ya deux
ans vous avez terminé premier du premier
parce que c'est vous et votre binôme en
tandem alors dans ma catégorie cercle et
les catégories à b la catégorie il y
avait trois oui il ya trois catégories
la catégorie binôme totalement fi bina
binôme totalement masculin et binômes
mixtes et dans le temps mais c'est le
quart d'heure x10 nomix voilà j'ai
terminé on a terminé premier en canoë
kayak et en tandem toujours pas en
course à pied
aimez vous produisez leur est permis ces
quatre jours
super et donc j'imagine qu'ils aient du
public et quelles sont les réactions des
du public vis-à-vis de ce genre de
manifestation alors il ya le public on
va dire azerty des gens qui vous suivent
oui me suivent et qui sont toujours
contents de nous retrouver d'être là et
puis il ya toujours cette part de public
étonné il est aveugle et il fait ça et
c'est un peu pour ça qu on le fait c'est
pour justement donner de l'espoir à
sexuelle et l'espoir montrer que oui
d'accord on est aveugle on est mal
voyants mais on vit d'autres vies
presque comme tout le monde
oui très bon voila fr au fait effet
voilà on essaye de ont fait quasiment
tout ce qu'à un voyant peut faire on le
fera de façon différente
non c'est pas du vélo fait du tandem
mais pourquoi pas mais on le fait
peut-être plus lentement
oui mais en fait et on a surtout la
volonté de faire et ce que vous me
disiez lors d'une interview précédente
c'est que vous quittiez habitué aux
sports dello sport collectif ce sport
d'équipé ce que vous m'avez dit c'est
que abadie moment n'est plus on est plus
de une personne
et bien ça c'est une équipe voilà vous
êtes d'accord oui complètement
après c'est le triathlon moi comme je
pratique on pratique seul mais au final
on s'entraîne toujours en équipe on se
retrouve toujours donc à quand même ce
phénomène équipe ça c'est ça reste
indéniable après quand c'est des équipes
en tandem comme on dit avec les guides
c'est vrai qu'ils forment aujourd'hui
des duos qui sont qui sont va à une
confiance aveugle j'allais dire dans ce
guide expression et moi pour courir avec
pas mal d'athlètes au niveau
international qui court aussi en
situation de soi de mal voyants soient
aveugles
c'est juste impressionnant de se dire à
une vitesse millions et aux vitesses
week où il et c'est de se dire
qu'ils ont une confiance complète sur
les guides et aujourd'hui ça fait des
duos qui sont qui sont à la performance
des munich va la force de s'entraîner
baron de serre tu progresses tu va
progresser partout et quelque part de
leurs gardes les gens ont quand il vient
de voir des épreuves comme ça c'est
plutôt positif parce que ça te permet
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle se sait
l'inclusion du handicap dans la société
en fait quelque part c'est de se dire le
handicap
moi je sais ce que j'ai dit une phrase
j'ai écrit une phrase le jour une
soufflante et j'ai écrit le handicap en
main si on veut bien lui donner cette
définition
a contrario il allie force pour réaliser
de grandes choses c'est à dire que le
handicap c'est ce qu'on se disait tout à
l'heure le handicap nous on ne vit pas
comme comme quelque chose de bleu quand
aujourd'hui la société elle veut nous
faire remplir une case et nous mettre
dans une case de handicap nous toutes
les personnes en situation de handicap
on veut pas cette case on veut pas cette
norme
on veut être on veut qu'on veut vivre
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui je cours
plus vite qu'une grande majorité des
valides je vais peut-être pédaler un peu
plus vite et je vais nager plus vite
donc c'est quoi qu'est ce que ça veut
dire mon handicap
oui j'ai un handicap parce que je suis
hors normes il manque un pied en fait
voilà prenons cet exemple après dans la
vie de tous les jours je n'ai pas plus
de gêne que ça à vivre et bien au
contraire
donc en fait c'est ça aujourd'hui le
handiski le handisport nous permet de
montrer à la société que on peut être en
situation de handicap mais on peut aussi
faire les mêmes activités on peut vivre
de la même manière et on peut se dire
que s'épanouir et quand on voit
désormais
des associations qui organisent les
moments comme ça déjà il ya ce côté très
convivial entre athlètes en situation de
handicap et ça c'est juste des bons
moments ils sont toujours partagés
et puis en même temps ça permet de
rayonner aussi sur la société et faire
changer les moeurs
parce que petit à petit nez bah c'est en
faisant des événements comme ça on en
discute ans l'atelier des choses comme
ça en étant ouvert parce que c'est comme
ça qu'on va faire changer de choses oui
et dominique est ce que vous dites papa
jean servat c'est une question que je
vous pose est-ce que quelquefois il n'ya
pas des petites choses très bête qui
vous facilitera la vie auxquelles nous
voyant par exemple on ne pense pas ou je
ne sais pas qu'est ce que messi il ya
plein de choses il ya plein de fiches de
randonnées
allez-y doubin des gens parlaient dans
la nature en venant tout à l'heure je
vous rassure c'est pas moi qui
conduisais c'est marie je parlais de mon
compte bancaire
oui il simplement aujourd'hui je ne peux
plus accéder tout seul à mon compte
bancaire parce que quand on met son mot
de passe
ouais c'est vous savez le petit carré où
il faut aller cliquer sur le chiffre qui
bouge tout le temps et voilà
bon c'est tout bête c'est tout simple
mais effectivement la banque à laquelle
j'appartiens ne nommerai pas mais à
penser simplement oublié zig et
l'accessibilité
voilà c'est tout un tas de petites
choses comme ça au quotidien alors oui
en rade
oui bien sûr mais bon voilà est-ce que
vous vous râlez pas de temps en temps
sur quelque chose maintenant mais faudra
les abonnés sûr je suis un coureur
oui mais sur 20 tout à fait mais oui
tous les jours on verra confier à
simplifier c'est que même demain on est
dans un monde où normalement on est
censé aller de l'avant vers les choses
justement pour tout le monde mais on va
tellement vite qu'on oublie nous qui wii
ou sais pas peut-être pas fait pas les
bonnes personnes
bon enfin bref bon on va trouver le
débat s'est dit samedi 15 juin donc pour
cette belle journée
oui on peut y assister ou peut
participer donc à triathlon en binôme et
vous brice alors vous rêvez de tokyo par
et il va rêver avec vous pour vous
allez une sélection jeux olympiques
c'est toujours quelque chose de
travailler sur leurs dix points il ya
très peu de dossards aux chiffres on est
conscient on voit que les règles se
resserre de plus en plus que le nombre
de candidats au moment donc où on se
donne les moyens on se bat et puis de
toute façon il ya plein de choses aussi
à faire des menaces par étapes
l'histoire est un jeu moi j'ai quand
même 38 ans donc j'en suis aussi
conscient est mon plaisir se monter mon
plaisir c'est de cette année concerne
ses produits plaisir de partager ses
index d'engins et puis de 17 à avancer
les choses sur le handicap et voilà
c'est comment merci et bravo et merci
pour votre exemple nous donner de la
force 5 à vous regarder c'est génial a
très vite
merci beaucoup des menus au royaume uni
qu'en barberis a au revoir
[Musique]